hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 71 of game
programming so last time we what do we
do last time I guess oh the sprite right
yeah I think that's what we did so we
have this fright last time and and our
game was just looking freaking superb
all right am i right except I think I
well this today basically what we're
going to cover and tell by the title is
well two things but one of the things is
actually removing projectiles that are
dead I guess all gone from our list so
that we don't keep rendering them
because that obviously wastes
performance and memory and everything
and also when I fix up these angles so
if you let's just focus on this one
other times the first of all angles if
you if we click say over here you can
notice that bad example if we click over
here you can notice that my mouse
pointer is like just below the line and
and you can see here that I can't
actually shoot in between that some
reason right for some weird reason here
I can't actually um well I can't angle
it correctly it's like it's snapping to
particular angles right and that's
pretty annoying what I want to do that
um so let's fix that and the fix is
pretty easy so one thing that you'll see
is all you might be able to guess here
that the reason is doing that is because
some there's some kind of issue with
Briss it with precision right so for
some reason at some point in time we
actually lose precision here and in arm
in programming like the most common
aspects of losing precision of course
are very very like there are a lot of
aspects there are a lot of possibilities
for why you actually lost precision but
probably the most common is the fact
that somewhere you know you're double or
your floor is being converted into an
integer okay and you're losing those
decimal points that's probably why okay
if you into really really really precise
things you might be losing um precision
by using a float instead of a double
because float is 32-bit doubles 64-bit
right so you might um you might be
losing a precision that way but
obviously not here because well first of
all not using floats but second of all
you know that precision that we would
lose if we use flows instead of doubles
would be
so minuscule that you know we actually
couldn't can tell so in this case it's
clearly integers somehow so we're right
now if we backtrack everything here and
I'm not gonna waste your time by showing
you this but you can see that in play
you know the angle that we get here
direction it's a double cry when we go
in to shoot it accepts a double it adds
a double here into wizard projectile
which is a double and then it angles NX
and NY which are both doubles so where's
the problem right and the problem
actually is actually an x and y so if we
um ctrl-click on ax we go back to the
throat which is an entity in the entity
class and you can say that it's public
integer X&Y that's what's happening so
if we go into was it projectile you'll
see that when we actually add on NX is
basically casting it into an int okay
that's the problem we don't want to do
that right what we want to do is not we
don't want to cast it to an int when we
actually calculate the new position we
want to cast it to an int when we
actually render it okay
so let's actually something that let's
go back to our let's go back to our
projectile over here and we'll just make
a protected protected double called X&Y
and that will obviously override these x
and y values because it's higher up in
the hierarchy so immediately we get this
problem where I we've got a problem you
know well actually you you you can
actually see that it is over it it is
indeed overriding them because in Wizard
projectile we instantly get an error and
over here we can just cast X&Y into
integers and that's all we need to do so
if we hit run hopefully and as you can
see there crystal smooth we've got
really really precise shots here yeah we
can get everything perfectly perfectly
right now this is bugging the crap out
of me so you can see that when we shoot
it's like it's coming out of his ass
well it's like it's coming out of well
not in the middle of him right so the
way that we can fix that is literally
just adjusting this slightly so maybe if
we
if you're actually seen from both or
something that might help to sound tried
a bit more you guys can really play
around with this so you can see that's a
bit too high up and why so I think why I
was pretty much perfect actually so
maybe only X needs to change that looks
like it's a bit too far across so maybe
like 12
so you're displaying about play around
with this and decide where you want it
to shoot from in fact maybe I will lift
the wire out by like two pixels or so
and there you go that looks pretty good
okay sway so that's how we fix up the
angles okay
now let's do the other thing that I
promised you guys that we would do and
that is while removing entities so if we
go into entity so if we go into level
and on facts where is our I think it is
in level actually I will be Vanara um I
think it might be in player no [ __ ] BIA
okay so in mob we have an array list
called projectiles so these are the
projectiles that belong to the player
let's just um in our update method here
which I don't even know we're calling
this somewhere let's just check okay
we're not calling it anyone in let's do
it in the move method so every time
we'll move will be four let's just print
out write the projectiles oops
projectiles dot sighs okay so that'll
basically tell us how many elements are
in this projectiles ArrayList let's run
that so every time we move they'll tell
us so we're at zero right now cool your
elements
let's click we've shot a bunch let's
move now okay
there are 58 elements you can see that
as we're moving along this number isn't
changing right there were long gone from
the screen but the RL is still does
contain those 58 shots and you can
imagine that if we shoot for ages you
can just see that on going up and the
problem is those things for each of
those 421 now elements right for each of
those 421 projectile projectiles the
game is still rendering them right the
game is still rendering and updating
them completely so in other words
actually to prove
if we go into was a projectile for
example and we just quickly print out
the exposition like look at that it is
still going it's at negative 6000 it is
still going and it's gonna keep going
for air by and you can say that well
negative 7000 that one for example over
here we go negative 12,000 and it's
keeping track of all these things now
this is very very bad for performance
okay very bad for the lungs and also
it's just not good it's not good for
gameplay either because projectile
shouldn't go forever right they should
stop so let's talk about how we can make
them stop okay now to make them stop we
basically need to define a range that's
how I like doing it okay
I just say basically that oh well if
it's traveled you know X amount if his
child X amount of tiles or whatever you
know if it's traveled like let's say 200
meters that's it like it you just
disappear okay so we can just play
around with that and then obviously
that's how we can get different ranges
as well for example you know some
weapons might have a range of ten some
weapons might have a range of 5000 who
knows so we can really get some really
nice gameplay elements and with that
without rules so for that we need to
basically keep track of the distance so
protected double distance and the
distance is going to be the distance
from the origin that arm our fingers
travel so over here let's just make a
method not calendar calendar in here
calculate distance okay and this will
literally just calculate a distance and
in fact I'm gonna make this an integer
so let's just print it so we can print
distance floss calculate distance all
right so let's create method and it will
be an integer okay sir
double Oh actually not won't be it'll be
a double not an integer
yeah that's fine so a double distance
will set a quote we'll just make that
equal to zero for now and we'll return
it okay so how do we calculate the
distance okay so we can use Pythagoras
theorem to do that and you guys should
be aware of how that works if I ever get
around to making that in depth series
actually I might soon because I I'll
talk about that later but if I do get
around to doing that I'll explain how
that works but it should be fairly
self-explanatory so the distance of
course it'd be square root of the
opposite side of the angle squared plus
the adjacent side of the angle so we can
use math dot square root the opposite
side so in other words well we can just
really use the distance here so X origin
X origin minus X that's how much is gone
and fact I think we really should
absolute this as well shouldn't why Oh
what you just probably do that at the
end we might get a square root of a
negative number
yeah let's okay I'll it's absolutely
absolute it now so we don't know we
don't want any imaginary numbers here so
we can I'll just do this this is the
same as squaring right and start
applying it plus the same thing for the
Y all right
so this will hopefully do if I don't
forget any brackets well this will
hopefully do is actually give us the
distance so let's just hop into here
let's carry that extra semicolon it's
hop in here and let's just check that
out okay
so that's what it is working it's just
the problem is there's multiple um
entities but yeah it looks like it's
working okay so what we could do now is
that is the math behind it by the way
it's just pretty much in the square root
of x squared plus y squared okay but I'm
just getting the UM doubtful distance
yeah so now that we've got that figured
out what we can do now is just basically
say that if our distance in fact instead
of calculate distance I might just
rename that because it was a it was
originally made it I was originally
meant to be a void method that's why I
named it um that's why I named it
calculate distance but since is going to
return something what's called distance
I'm pretty fricking saying okay distance
again suede so what what we can say now
is that if distance is greater right
than our range then essentially let's
just remove it let's remove that element
and that seems to work for some reason
so we need to remove it from them from
level so how do we remove an element
from a level okay that is the big
question well the way that we do that in
the our case is we just really need to
remove it from a projectile list yeah so
what we need to do is we need to
basically say that if we remove a
particular element we're to just remove
it from our Y let's go back to mob we're
gonna remove it from our projectiles
list so how do we do that there are
several ways of doing that but the way
that I'm probably gonna show you guys
how to do this is going to be well I
guess the easiest to probably explain so
what we can do simply in mob is we can
just have a method and the reason I'm
doing it this way is actually because it
will universally just clean up how our
entire game
in update there is not that method here
that we're not actually calling right so
we should be calling it and the reason
that we're not calling it well that the
reason the work kind of not calling it
here is because it's actually being
overwritten by player so that's really
the issue here but what we should so we
can't really do it here but where we
should do it is probably in in our
player class so now in our player class
since you know these projectiles do kind
of belong to play off we can just make a
method here called clear right and let's
just create that method here and in
clear right or we'll do is we'll just
say that sorry for in I equals 0 is less
than our projectiles dot size I plus
plus so for all the projectiles right
all we'll do is we'll say we'll just
make a projectile cake called
projectiles get i right and we'll just
say that um you know if p dot is removed
all right which we conveniently have a
method you know entity thing called is
removed and without return gjermund we
can say that if if it's removed right
then projectiles don't get sorry
projectiles don't remove hi ok simple as
that
and what that should do is essentially
to remove that projectiles from our
screen so let's let's just try that out
quickly all right we can't really tell
here but if we go into the size of our
things on mob if we just get back to
printing so size
plus projectiles sighs we go back to
printing this then you can see that size
is actually zero right now so it stays
like that and then gets removed so that
range is actually pretty long so let's
change that let's go back into and what
just to emphasize is I'll make this less
on import calendar god let's change the
range to like 20 all right that should
be pretty damn low okay right so the
size of that projectiles thing is
getting a lot less which is pretty damn
awesome in fact was you're already so if
we change the range to something like 2
and which is really just getting about
to zero start away okay so even though
our side says zero for some reason they
are actually still being rendered so
let's go back and fix that
if we go into well first of all what are
they getting rendered right they're
getting rendered in okay so let's just
quickly check out where this meth is
actually being cold
so references workspace in level data
Randa okay so okay I see so it's just
rendering entities mmm that's
interesting yeah okay so I can
definitely see what's happening
the reason that this is happening is
because it's it's some it's not actually
removing it from the entity is removing
it from the projectiles but it's not
removing it from the entities so what we
should really do here is probably
reconfigure this game to to have
projectiles separate from entities
because if we do have them as entities
as we have now they kind of screw up
right so we'll talk about fixing that
next time just because it's gonna take a
while to actually wire everything but I
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
game programming if you did please hit
the like button and I'll see you guys
tomorrow with a new episode bye guys
you